I didn't ghost you [ __ ] Burbank you're
stupid all right
is that yours I'll do it
I like oh boy it's been on like a couple
times what is it my brother like on that
show he's great
you level because we're in it's a very
supporting environment yeah my brother
is um he's a reptilian Casey's yeah yeah
yeah it's it he gets it I don't I think
she's more out there do you think it's
just that you think that's all it is in
the whole universe of things let me see
something I know for a fact right it's
just because it's endless galaxies upon
galaxies there's obviously libraries
yeah out there okay I just don't think
that they're here yet I believe
obviously that there is life out there
there's probably there's probably like a
Star Trek there's like you know mean an
alien race that's so above us they're
not [ __ ] with us crime right right
you know so then when I [ __ ] with the
prime directive you know me so they're
like so how did human beings come
evolved weird how do we what does that
jump from monkeys to humans what
evolution no but there's a gap in there
they can't explain the missing link it's
called where is that what is that you're
saying that from fish we didn't come
from fish lady
well how does evolution does it come
fish and well we know it went from let
me see well you have a wish - lizard
lizard Sylar
all right so yeah soon okay okay let's
go to it and do this okay this is what I
thought and just I'm not smart and so
how do you explain Korean language have
you seen that looks like alien writing
no does it looks like something right
but if they look at an A or or W sound
that looks alien - we're not from
[ __ ] right right right but that
really looks like some alien [ __ ] okay
so what you're saying to me is is that
Asians or aliens there may be more alien
than you are then maybe even Arabic
shit's weird yeah I mean like dude
there's a lot crazy [ __ ] they think
that's what you're saying is it the only
planes were giants okay let's go back I
ain't Giants a big kid they were giant
there's a giant there was a she's of
giant I know I said they say have skulls
and they found Scott I know beings then
Tutankhamun was not if they found Andre
the Giant skull right
I would gigantism right it'll go oh my
god they were giants back then no but it
was Andre the Giant have you they're
even bigger than Andre the Giant like
Andre John was like seven foot right
like we're talking like a grown man goes
well also thrown giant dude you're
saying to me right now that they found a
body a sushi chef on a smoke break right
you're you're saying to me right now
jack that they found 12 foot men bout
the bones of I don't know the exact
number that and I'll get murdered on
that number so I can't say by lava [ __ ]
it's bigger than seven foot we wouldn't
go crazy over 7 foot people but 9 foot
you're saying like really oh yeah and
that dude how many just one or that
statue that they say is alive like have
you seen that statue it's like Oh like
we're going into like crazy town USA no
it's that crazy don't you
you should into it you two nutjobs are
those three guys from the x-files you
know those nerds
Lindy what are they calling me to try to
do a spin-off showed and failed I don't
know yeah that's what you guys are I
just saw it now no no don't do that with
your [ __ ] white eyebrows in my face
why I'm not but I do believe that I
would believe in simulation theory
before that yeah and that I believe that
I don't believe in flat earth but I
think there's something that is making
these guys think that yeah I'm like that
whether smoke there's fire that not that
there is a flat plane or anything like
that but something isn't adding up
that they're going [ __ ] crazy like
and that could be simulation theory like
they went all the way down you're saying
they're going all the way down like they
like keep breaking down molecules more
and more more to this one scientist said
he's found binary code like ones and
zeros like so deep into what you keep
slicing and dicing ones and zeros that
sounds like a computer program to me so
I don't [ __ ] know I don't know i and
here's a whole thing nobody knows except
for the highest levels of [ __ ] NASA
of what's really going on if you sit
there and go NASA's told us everything
that's true all the time you're in
denial
they've Lydell they've been caught lying
I lie all the time so I know that
they're lying human nature that we let
spod cast is doing well but it's not
billion-dollar I know but let me say
something right now right i here's the
things that i know all right
my immediate life like in my inner
circle you know like what I do for a
living might you know the bigger your la
you know but I see what I see and I
experienced what I experienced all this
other stuff right it's just what you
experience is actually a controlled
hallucination you already have
preconceived things that are hardwired
into your brain what you see is what
Spri conceivably so you're actually
looking at the world not inside out but
outside it dude I respect the [ __ ] out
of that now listen the moon she's
[ __ ] dating me man
all right yeah don't give her [ __ ]
fantasy fantasy [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
white weirdo man right now alright
that's a great name white weirdo yeah so
what I'm saying do to you right now
you're saying to me right now right is
that right now this is all a
hallucination that I mixed not a
hologram it's a hologram okay you might
have an anxiety attack thinking I'm like
seriously like going tunnel vision right
now cuz I mean there's crazy nothing
like the thing about this is like when
you argue quote conspiracy theories yeah
you're literally like and there are
crazy people that are involved like we
were just talking about that we are
courting a a bunch of crazy people like
I get called a gay Jew she'll constantly
you know I'm not gay I'm not you I'm not
sure I'm your headline a Jew I'm not my
meaning yeah I sent you okay you get a
you get us if you're looking for retail
Jew you can't afford that you go a
99-cent store you get a [ __ ] Armenian
that's what you get so so what you're
six your reasonable skeptic but you're
not if we call it spiritual skepticism
you just saw you are question the
official narrative because there's a lot
most people should do but they don't
what they do is they rely on because
there's over the last like since the
cleanse there's been a complete change
or at least they were more open about it
and how the news is delivered ah there
was consolidation of all the media under
one group of six people that six
companies owned all 90% of media and
they control the [ __ ] message and
that message is directly relate to what
they make money and then that is god
gold oil [ __ ] drugs okay that's
that's the trillion dollar business the
Hollywood [ __ ] is the billion dollar
they don't give a [ __ ] about that it's
the big bucks so there's a manipulation
that goes down with that and I'm not
trying to change anything I say the
people I go our show is a compilation
porn of conspiracies okay we take the
greatest hits and we talk about let me
ask you something just say like making
the ice-cream man and come to I think I
think he's a part of it this man
be dues how [ __ ] his face got all red
everybody blows up has some weird CIA
connection say something right now
is there a starter kit I can get into
like a book I can read it I think there
is what is it I think you should start
with JFK start looking into the
assassination of JFK start looking
really deep
[Music]